♪ You thought you were perfect ♪
♪ So did I ♪
♪ Ain't nobody perfect who am I ♪
♪ I'm a good person over five ♪
- I think they only had me
shopping like once for sneakers.
- Right, in the sneaker place?
- Yeah.
♪ Ain't nobody perfect who am I ♪
- Thank you so much.
- See you tomorrow man.
- See you tomorrow.
Gorgeous.
♪ Daddy working on me ♪
♪ Hey, I been working on me ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ I been working on me ♪
- Remember that one time I beat you
and you punched a hole in the wall?
- Yeah.
- Let's see what's going on here.
It's golf.
(ball hitting pucks)
(swift sighs)
- Better not film this way.
- (laughs) Only film that way.
Big save, huge save!
(ball hitting pucks)
Oh, nice job!
Big turnover.
(laughter)
♪ You thought you were perfect, so did I ♪
- Nine years ago, eight years ago I
started a company with my brother
called VaynerMedia with one agenda
which was in Star Wars terms,
to build a communications Death Star,
to be able to point to anything that
I want to do for the next 30 years.
- [Woman] Very interesting,
you're very ambitious as well.
- Yeah, but a macro very ambitious
and in a micro an amazing
amount of patience
like building a client
service business over
the last eight years
is not necessarily like
what a lot of my friends think I should be
spending my time, wasting my time on.
But I understand why I'm doing it.
- [Woman] Right.
- Big companies are really bad at math
and small companies are really bad at art.
You know the big brands want to spend
two million dollars on making a video
and using Nielsen Ratings
and their opinions
and the small companies
think it's all math
and that's why they end
up running out of time
because KAK and LTV are fine,
but when you're not
actually building a brand
you become unbelievably vulnerable
to whatever platform you're
doing your KAK and LTV on.
So by creating that friction
of the two disciplines,
we've been able to build something
and it's starting to really resonate
so we've been growing very
quickly in the last two years.
I think at first people were trying
to figure out what we
were doing or we were
coming from such a different angle,
back to the early days
where you and I met,
all that talk was unheard
of for Madison Avenue.
You know, Pepsi and Unilever were like
where's your canned lions?
It's why within our organization I've done
such a big push for voice.
One, I believe in it but two,
I needed 850 people to
remember we're trading
attention not social media.
I didn't want our company to become
what I make fun of which is you become so
religious about what got you there that
you know it was very
important for the company
not to think of ourselves as social media
because if I started the
company eight years earlier
when I was doing the wine business we
would have been Google search and email.
To me it's whatever the
Arbitrage is you know
and then understanding when
things get too expensive,
not expensive enough and just looking
at it all agnostically.
Even my content you know why your
19 year old son thinks it's cool,
it's I don't even think
about content without
thinking about distribution.
I don't ever think about content without
the context of the
platform and most of all
I never think about content unless
I think about the empathy for
the end user who's consuming it.
- [Man] Like this is almost
the best it ever gets.
- You're saying I brought
the greatest weather
to Helsinki in it's history?
- [Man] Finnish summer is short,
this year it was Thursday,
so this is useful.
- It's unbelievable.
What are the hours that it's light out?
It's so light when.
- [Man] In summer time it
doesn't get dark at all.
- Ever?
No I know but right now.
- [Man] Now for the next two months, no.
- Just never dark,
that's so awesome.
Hello, how are you?
- I'm good how are you?
- It's so nice to meet you.
- What's the worst
mistake a company can make
in online marketing?
- There's so many mistakes, I think one of
the biggest mistakes they can make is they
fall in love with the math.
Too many people with online marketing are
not doing marketing they're doing sales.
Everything is so predicated on last touch
attribution, customer acquisition costs
it's just math, math, math.
This Google ad costs 19 cents to get
somebody here and that's better than
22 cents on Facebook
or 39 cents on Snapchat
and they leave it very
basic they only look at
the math and so the
number one mistake in 2018
that I see is an addiction to just math
without putting brand or marketing
or the long term impacts of becoming only
a math based marketer
or even scarier,
using vanity metrics like impressions,
or likes as a proxy to the success
of their business or the cost of the CPM.
I see so many people buying programmatic
banner ads because it's five dollars CPM
but not a soul on earth, none of you
actually see it.
So math and then the worst
version of it is math that doesn't matter.
- I think you start with content
from people like me.
That's why I do it.
I think the only way a person changes
their mind is by hearing
a different perspective.
And so maybe I resonate for some people,
I don't need it to be me.
I need it to be somebody like me.
You have to hear
alternatives and positivity
too many people were raised to be insecure
to follow the system
and I'm very passionate
as you know to break through,
through a different style.
You know I've got my aggressive style
and I think other people
have passive styles
and whatever works but you've
got to hear it a different way.
Look at this, the odds of you existing are
the same as two million people rolling a
trillion sided dice and all landing on
the same number.
- That's mental.
(laughing)
- And it's about perspective,
it's just about perspective.
- Absolutely.
- Coming.
- Thanks a lot for your
time guy, I appreciate it.
- Thank you bud, thank you.
Finland is one of the most interesting
markets in the world for somebody like me
because I'm unemotional meaning marketing
to me is just, whether it's Outdoor
or Google or Facebook or
Snapchat or Instagram.
Or drawing on a building,
or a flier or television
I'm just unemotional, I don't care
I don't love digital,
I don't like technology.
I like attention because
if you have attention
then you can tell somebody
what you're about.
- Hey I'm Hexar.
- Gary. How are you my friend?
You okay?
- I'm okay.
- What happened?
- So these guys are too old and strong.
- For our sports we have the Wilson
and some other brands right so.
- Yeah let's sit down just
gonna go grab a coffee.
That's what I think the new world's about,
when you look at wrestling, WWF or WWE
or tennis when it had
broadcasting on network.
Here's the perfect
example, in 1947 in America
horse racing, boxing and baseball
number one, two and three.
Right, baseball number one.
Because the radio was
distributing baseball,
horse racing and boxing.
I think that if you actually own a league
like this you can go make a deal with
Snapchat or Twitter or Facebook,
for distribution.
You might really be able to do something.
I guess where I'm going with this
as we're wrapping up.
I think the next frontier
for product companies is to
become a media company.
Instead of advertising, which is renting
you guys have the money
and now the distribution.
I mean look, I'm filming
a vlog this is you know I'm doing reality
television on Youtube and Facebook.
I think there's something very interesting
in taking your assets
and I mean YouTube and
Facebook needs content.
It's like the old ESPN remember?
You had to fill it with something.
Something to think about.
Are you filming your speeches?
- Nope.
- You should.
Get somebody to film them and post them
on Facebook and link them.
- That's a very good point.
- Do it.
- Yeah.
- Let it travel outside the four walls.
- To your point, put a flag in the ground.
I think you can, I think there will be
some room to play.
You weren't good at.
You weren't good at paper football?
- Try it, no the other side.
- Got it.
- Oh that's a good slide!
- Jeez, it really goes.
Hold on now I'm getting competitive.
That was good.
Yeah, you ever play this?
You remember this, that
was a touchdown D-rock
and then you know like I used to beat like
honestly in eighth grade
I went 48 and one.
And when Ian Heffernan
beat me in paper football
I lost my shit like
completely, got detention
for a month, because I like
rampaged the whole like.
Remember how fun that was?
- Yeah it was good.
(gentle piano music)
(group speaking)
- Yeah I'm doing video.
You cold?
- A little!
- Cool huh?
- Very cool,
my Dad he's gonna love this.
- [Camera Man] Alright guys.
How was that experience?
- Super rad, I feel
like a nice Finnish boy.
(gentle music)
- Now we can go here.
- Before you go
(group speaking and laughing)
- I like that,
what is that?
- [Man] I really appreciate
you taking the chance
to make something memorable for you.
- It's really cool.
- [Man] Because I need to plan to retouch.
- To make it nice, yeah.
- [Man] And because of the V,
I have this optical illusion, do you see?
- That's cool.
- It's impossible for you
to be sitting in the V
and there could be more of these V's.
- Can you scoot down?
- I think the answer to everything,
right now is more.
Everyone's like,
"What should I do for my personal brand?"
And I'm like as much as possible.
If you can do a daily podcast, yes.
If you can do a vlog, yes.
If you can post five times a day
on Instagram, yes.
If you can do thirty posts for stories
for Instagram and Snapchat, yes.
If you can reply to 50 people on Twitter,
to me the answer is yes
and so what the vlog
does, it opened up everything else.
Now, I document, I don't create.
Right, so even this clip, even this is
very meta because now it might be titled
for Facebook like
"How somebody should be thinking about
building out their team" and here it is!
I didn't have to sit and write
you know what I mean?
Hey everybody, I'm Gary Vanderchuck.
Thanks for coming out tonight,
I got to say hello to a
bunch of you but the ones
that came in a little later,
I'm looking forward to
saying hello in a little bit.
We're gonna film an "Ask Gary V" show.
For me, the number one rule that
everybody here should think about,
whether you're building a personal brand
or a business is not to create friction
for the audience.
So if they want to watch
my vlog on Facebook
I'm going to give it to them.
If they wanna watch it on YouTube,
I'm gonna give it to them.
If they want to listen to it on a podcast,
I think the biggest mistake people
here make, and when I say here I mean
fucking everyone,
is they make content
for them and their behaviors not for
everybody elses'.
I think for example a lot of these
video stars better start getting
real serious about audio because video
is going to be on decline
because video takes time.
Really nice meeting you man.
- Nice to meet you.
- Real pleasure.
I'll take you guys out to dinner,
you and the winner.
- Sounds good.
- We'll have a nice time.
- Then we watch the game.
- My office is literally,
my office to Madison Square Garden,
is like from here to
that first small white building.
- What's it like?
- I'm on 30th and 10th,
it's a new project.
It used to be the railroads,
now it's called Hudson Yards.
It used to be old railroad tracks
so literally, right Droq?
What do you think?
Like from here to like, two avenues.
- They were going to build
Madison Square Garden there.
- That's correct.
- Yeah.
- And they were gonna build the Jets
and Giants Stadium there originally.
So that's where our office is,
so I'm right there.
- Okay.
- Alright, I'm good right?
I'm gonna say hello to
a couple more people but
I'm gonna try to get some rest.
What time is tomorrow?
- This is tricky, it's 11.
- Yeah it's just now getting dark so it's
11 o'clock.
- [Gary] Alright D-rock,
I think we're out.
♪ Hey, I been working on me ♪